[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
على خطتها لبدء الوساطه والحوار مع كييف
دون بحث التفاصيل
من الدعم
تزيد انتاجها العسكري لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه
برلين تدين حكم الاعدام على مواطن الماني
من اصل ايراني وتطرد دبلوماسيين ايرانيين
العربيه تستاصل الاوضاع الانسانيه شمال
غربي سوريا بعد الزلزال وتنقل شهادات
الكوادر الطبيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه اكد كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين على ان الصين تثمن
رغبه روسيا في تسويه الصراع مع اوكرانيا
سلميا مؤكدا ستلعب دورا في تسويه الصراع
بين روسيا واوكرانيا وستكون موضوعيه وعلى
الحياد فيما يتعلق بالازمه الاوكرانيه في
المقابل وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه اكدت انها
اطلعت على خطه بكين ولم تناقش تفاصيلها
مشيره الى ان وجهات النظر بشان القضايا
الدوليه بين بكين ومووسكو متطابقه الى حد
كبير اشارت موسكو الى تقديرها لموقف الصين
بشان قضيه اوكرانيا ووصفته بالمتوازنه
العلاقات الدوليه اليوم اكثر صعوبه لم
تتحسن بعد انهيار النظام ثنائي القطب بل
على العكس اصبحت اكثر حده في هذا الصدد
يلعب التعاون على الساحه الدوليه بين
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه والاتحاد الروسي
كما اكدنا مرارا وتكرارا دورا مهما في
استقرار الوضع الدولي بالطبع نحن ننتظر من
رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه ان يقوم
بزياره لروسيا اتفقنا على ذلك في وقت سابق
نعرف اكتر من ضيفنا نادي الرونق الصحفيه
الصينيه معنا مباشره من بكين نادر اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه ما الذي نعرفه حتى
الان عن تفاصيل هذه الوساطه الصينيه
لاحلال السلام في اوكرانيا
اهلا ومرحبا بكم موقف الصين تجاه ازمه
اوكرانيا وهو منذ بدايتها واضحه ومستمر
وهو ان الصين تقف بجانب السلام
والحوار والدعوه الى
البدل التفاوض بالفور ووقف اطلاق النار
وايجاد حل سياسي
ومستدامه ومتوازنه لهذه الازمه عبر حوار
والتفاوض
وكذلك
السين ستؤلين السلسله او مبادرات
حل الازمات الاوكرانيه
ويعني فيها الدعوات او التاكيد
مجددا للاحترام
نعلم جيدا ان الصين هي اقرب الى روسيا
منها الى اوكرانيا مسؤول اوكرانيا رفيع
المستوى قال
[موسيقى]
هذه الوساطه فاعتقد هناك استجابه ولكن
يعني
الذي يجب
الذي يجب استجابه والدلع دور
ربما كيف عندما تطلع على التفاصيل ربما
تغير موقفها وربما تستجيب انتم في الصين
هل لديكم اي تسريبات اي معلومات حول
تفاصيل هذه الخطه الصينيه لانهاء الحرب
الاوكرانيه في عامها الاول
التفاصيل لم تولين بعد ولكن هناك بعض يعني
النقاط هو يعني تاكيد مجددا للاحترام
السياده دوله ووحده اراضيها وكذلك مبادئ
يعني
الاغراض الوثائق الامم المتحده وكذلك
احترام واهتمام بجميع الاهتمامات الامنيه
لكل الدول وكذلك الدعم لجميع الجهود
الراميه الى
الراميه الى حل السلمي لهذه الازمه وكذلك
لا يمكن القيام بالحروب النوويه ولا يوجد
فائزه في حروب النوويه وكذلك الدعوه الى
الامن لمنشات النوويه المدنيه
وعدم الهجوم على المحطه
توريد الكهرباء بالنوويه وكذلك
معرضه استخدام اسلحه كيماويه جميل طيب
ولكن نادر هذه الوساطه الصينيه او هذه
الخطه الصينيه للتوسط بين روسيا واوكرانيا
لانهاء الحرب تاتي بعد ايام قليله من حديث
امريكي مسؤولين امريكيين كانوا يحذرون
الصين من تقديم اسلحه لروسيا لاستخدامها
في الحرب في اوكرانيا هل خطه الوساطه هذه
لها علاقه بهذا التحذير الامريكي
ليس هناك
اصلا
تقدم الاسلحه لاي طرف في النداء ليس طرف
في النزاع ولا تريد تقديم اي اسلحه لاي
طرف وتريد احلال السلام بدلا من تقديم
ولكن الولايات المتحده هي من يعني تقدم
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا باستمرار
باختصار لو سمحت من وجهه نظرك الشخصيه هل
تعتقد ان بكين قادره على انهاء الحرب
الاوكرانيه
اعتقد هذا يتوقف على التحركات الجانب
الولايات المتحده
يعني وهو كان يجب يلعب دور اكثر
لاحلال السلام لان هو
من يعني يقدم اسلحه لاوكرانيا باستمرار
دون مراعاه امنيه وحياه
المواطنين في اوكرانيين وكذلك الاضرار
الناجمه ان هذه الاستمرار هذا الحرب
للدول الاوروبيه نادي الرونج شكرا جزيلا
لك من تكيه
[موسيقى]
على هامش انطلاقي اجتماعي مجموعه بوخارست
تسعه هكذا الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
التزام بلاده بتقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا حتى
تسترجع سيادتها وحريتها والدفاع ايضا عن
كل شبر من اراضي حلف النيتو
تحدثت مع الرئيس زيلينسكي وناقشنا موضوع
الحريات والديمقراطيات في اوروبا والعالم
معا سنواصل تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا حتى
تتمكن من استرجاع حريتها وسيادتها قدمنا
مساعده امنيه حاسمه لاوكرانيا ودعما ماليا
للمزيد من اللاجئين وضمننا حصول اوكرانيا
على الخدمات الاساسيه خلال العام المنصرم
بفضل دوري كم الريادي عززنا ايضا حلف
النيتو سوف ندافع عن كل شبر من اراضي حلف
الناتو في هذه اللحظه المهمه نتطلع
لمناقشه الخطوات اللاحقه التي سوف نتخذها
لابقاء حلفنا قويا ونتمكن من ردع اي عدوان
مقبل
نتابع من وارسو العاصمه الفلنديه حسين
قنابل الى هناك حسين اهلنا بك معنا ما هي
مخرجات هذا الاجتماع بين بايدن ومجموعه
بوخارست 9 او دول اوروبا الشرقيه الاعضاء
في
مساء الخير صهيب هذه المخرجات اختصرها
الجانب الامريكي فيما صدر عنه اذ اكد ان
القاده الذين اجتمعوا في وارسو اكدوا اولا
على التزامهم بالدعم الثابت لاوكرانيا
اكدت الولايات المتحده خلال الاجتماع
التزامها بالحفاظ على الامن على جانبي
الاطلسي اي الجانبين الامريكي والاوروبي
للاطلسي كما اكد المجتمعون انهم يحرسون
على تعزيز الوضع الدفاعي عند الخاصره
الشرقيه
وهنا كرر الرئيس بايدن الالتزام الصلب
للولايات المتحده بالبند الخامس من
المعاهده المؤسسه
واعرب المجتمعون في وارسو عن
تاكيدهم على ان الدفاع المشترك ووحده
الموقف سيكونان عنوانين رئيسيين خلال قمه
النيتو التي ستنعقد في فيلينيوس عاصمه
ليتوانيا في الثاني عشر والثالث عشر من
حزيران يونيو المقبل كان لافتا جدا صهيب
كانت لافته اشاره بايدن الى البند الخامس
في المعاهده المؤسسه للاطلسي وهذا البند
ينص على ان الدفاع المشترك يعني ان اي
هجوم على دوله عضو في حلف الناتو يعتبر
هجوما على كل اعضاء الحلف هذه اشاره نادره
من الرئيس بايدن شخصيا الى المند الخامس
من معاهده النيتو نعم حسين زياره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ان كان الى العاصمه
الاوكرانيه اكياب والطريقه التي زار بها
اوكرانيا وكذلك زيارته الى وارسو العاصمه
البولنديه كانت لافته وحافله في نفس الوقت
نتائج هذه الزياره
ومحصلتها معك لو سمحت
طبعا لا يمكن فصل زياره بايدن المفاجئه
الى كييف عن زيارته التي كانت مبرمجه
مسبقا الى وارسو هو انطلق الى اوكرانيا من
بولندا وعاد من اوكرانيا الى بولندا عبر
محطه قطارات في منطقه الحدود الاوكرانيه
البولنديه في جنوب الشرق بولندا الرحله
بالقطار بالمناسبه تستغرق 10 ساعات من
كياف الى الواقعه جنوب الشرق ابولندا كان
لافتا تعليق الرئيس البولندي على زياره
بايدن المفاجئه الى حيث قال اندريه دوده
ان هذه الزياره رفعت معنويات المدافعين عن
اوكرانيا لانها اشاره الى ان العالم الحر
والقائد الاكبر فيه اي رئيس الولايات
المتحده يقف الى جانب المدافعين عن
اوكرانيا كما قال الرئيس البولندي حرفيا
ولكن يجب القول ان معنويات البولنديين
ايضا
زياره بايدن الى وارسو بدليل ان هذه
القلعه الملكيه التي تبدو خلفي والتي ادلى
بايدن بعد ظهور امس بخطابه من داخلها حضر
الخطاب مئات البولنديين الذين حضروا من كل
الاعمار شاهدناهم داخل القلعه كانوا
يلوحون بالعلمين الامريكي والبولندي صفقوا
بحماس لبعض عبارات بايدن ومن بينها
العباره التي قال فيها ان اوكرانيا لن
تكون ابدا نصرى روسيا بوتا سيخسر والوحشيه
لن تنتصر قفوا احرارا وقفوا فخوري قال
بايدن للبولنديين الذين كانوا يستمعون
اليه عندما تعرفون من يقف الى جانبكم هذا
يحدث كل الفرق هذه العبارات لبايدن لقيت
حماسا كبيرا وتسفيقا حارا من جانب مئات
البولنديين الذين كانوا يستمعون اليه في
القلعه الملكيه الواقعه خلفي اما اجتماعه
اليوم بمجموعه بوخارست 9 فقط طمئ
المشاركين في هذا الاجتماع الى ان
الولايات المتحده فعلا ملتزمه
بتقديمي كل الدعم ليس فقط لاعضاء حلف
الناتو بل الدول المتحالفه مع الحلف كما
تداولت وسائل اعلام بولنديه هذه الليله
صهيب حسين قنيبر من وارسو شكرا جزيلا
قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني بين ولا
بريطانيا تتقدم في انتاج الاسلحه لمساعده
اوكرانيا على الدفع بالقوات الروسيه في
الربيع مؤكدا ان لندن بدات احماء خطوط
انتاجها لاستبدال الاسلحه المرسله الى
اوكرانيا وزياده انتاج قذائف المدفعيه
[موسيقى]
منذ عام تقريبا والعقوبات الغربيه تتساقط
على روسيا من كل حدب وصوب السبب حربها على
اوكرانيا طبعا الا ان تلك العقوبات رغم
الالم الذي سببته للروس لم ترضع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عن الاستمرار في
حربه فعلى الرغم من انسحاب العديد من
الشركات الاجنبيه خلال الفتره الماضيه من
البلاد نجح الروس في استنساخ ماركات اخرى
فراى العالم بدائل محليه عن ستاربكس
وماكدونالدز وغيرها من الشركات العالميه
لكن لا شك ان الوضع على الارض اكثر تعقيدا
اذ يشعر العديد من المواطنين بانها في حرب
بارده وبانهم محاصرون لكن رغم ذلك لم تكسر
العقوبات ظهر الكرملين ولم توقف الحرب
ايضا وبالتالي لم تنجح
[موسيقى]
تهديدات روسيا باستخدام النووي مستمره
ودائما على لسان نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي لمدف فبعد اعلان بلاده امس
الانسحاب من اتفاقيه نيو ستارت النوويه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتبني مجلس
الدمى
ستدافع عن نفسها بكل وسيله بما في ذلك
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه محذرا من ان
العالم اجمع سيكون على حافه صراع شامل اذا
اصرت واشنطن على هزيمه موسكو من جهته اتهم
رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي فيلودن الولايات
المتحده بتدمير بنيه الاستقرار الدولي عبر
توقفها عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها ورفضها
لمقترحات روسيا بشان قضايا الامن العالمي
[موسيقى]
الحرب الاوكرانيه لم تكمل عاما كاملا بعد
لكنها اثبتت انها واحده من اكثر الحروب
الحديثه تكلفه ماديا وبشريا لنتحدث
مشاهدينا عن هذه الخسائر بالارقام وفقا
للقياده العامه الاوكرانيه فان اجمالي
الخسائر البشريه للقوات الروسيه بلغت ما
يقرب من 120 الفا من الافراد العسكريين
اما المصادر الرسميه الروسيه فاعترفت
بمقتل
5973 جنديا فقط حتى ديسمبر الماضي فيما
قدم المسؤولون الامريكيون مؤخرا تقييمات
للخسائر البشريه على الجانبين تتراوح بين
180 الف الى 200 الف قتيل وجريح روسي ومئه
الف قتيل وجريح اوكرانيا اما بالنسبه
لخسائر العتاد فان اجمالي الخسائر
القتاليه للقوات الروسيه وفقا للقياده
العامه الايرانيه بلغت 380 دبابه مصفحه
واكثر من سته الاف مركبه قتاليه و2000
نظام مدفعي واكثر من 400 نظام صاروخي
واكثر من 200 نظام دفاع جوي واكثر من
1200 مسيره
في روسيا تراشق وانتقادات متبادله بين
الدفاع الروسيه وتصريحات قائد مجموعه التي
تحمل رسائل خفيه تعكس حجم التوتر الحاصل
والتي تنظر بحدوث ازمه عسكريه اضافيه لوضع
ميداني معقد يواجه العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الاوساط الروسيه منشغله هذه الايام
بالخلاف المعلني بين الجيش الروسي ومجموعه
فاجنر اخر التصريحات مطالبه قائد فاجنر
بالضغط الشعبي على مؤسسه الجيش لتزويد
مقاتله في الذخيره الدعوه تحمل اتهامات
مبطنه لوزير الدفاع بتعمد تعطيل وصول
الذخيره والسلاح الى جبهات القتال مراقبون
يرون ان جدوى الانقسام يغذيها تعطل حسم
المعارك في باخموت وبعضهم يرى انها محاوله
من قائد فاجنر لتبرير عدم حسم معركه
باخموت بالقاء اللوم على الجيش في موقف
ممثل لقائد الشيشان الذي حمل قاده في
الجيش الروسي الاخفاق فيليمان وزير الدفاع
الروسي ما يزال يلتزم الصمت تجاه اتهامات
فاغنر لكن الجيش تعرض لتغيرات كثيره لقاده
المعارك خلال العام الاول من الحرب في
اوكرانيا الصراع بين الجيش الروسي وفاغنير
يشير الى حاله من الانقسام ستكون لها
ارتدادات مع استمرار المعارك وهو الامر
الذي دفع بالرئيس الروسي الى توعد من
وصفهم بالخونه داخل روسيا بالعقاب
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه السعوديه تدين
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه مدينه
نابلس وتطالب المجتمع الدولي بالضغط على
تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
الى وقف المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
تاتي في وقت تواجهه فيه الحكومه اليمينيه
الاسرائيليه انتقادات بشان قرار منح اذن
باثر رجعي لبؤر استيطانيه متعدده في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله وبناء منازل جديده
عبر الضفه الغربيه المحتله وغزه ينتشر
الياس ويغذي الغضب كل مستوطنه جديده تشكل
حاجزا اخر على طريق السلام جميع الانشطه
الاستيطانيه غير قانونيه بموجب القانون
الدولي ويجب ان تتوقف
الادانه الامميه هذه جاءت بعد ان اعلنت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل عشره واصابه
نحو مئه اخرين برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
خلال اقتحامها للبلده القديمه في مدينه
نابلس واوضحت في بيان ان الكثير من
الحالات مصابه بالرصاص الحي بينما اصيب
اكثر من 250 بالاختلاف وانسحبت القوات
الاسرائيليه من البلده القديمه في نابلس
بعد اقتحامها حاره الشيخ مسلم وسط اطلاق
نار كثير
[موسيقى]
وزير الخارجيه الفلسطينيه رياض المالكي
قال ان السلطه الفلسطينيه طلبت عقد اجتماع
طارئ لمجلس الامن الدولي لادانه ما ترتكبه
اسرائيل من جرائم بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
واخرها مجزره نابلس المالكيه اضاف ان
الجانب الفلسطيني طلب ايضا عقد اجتماع
طارئ لمجلس الجامعه العربيه على مستوى
المندوبين وكذلك لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
بهدف الادانه الجماعيه والفرديه من قبل
الدول لمجازر الاحتلال
من نيويورك معنا مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم
المتحده رياض منصور سيد رياض شكرا جزيلا
لك على تلبيه دعوه العربيه هذا المساء
بدايه هل تلقيتم اي رد على طلب السلطه
الفلسطينيه عقد اجتماع عاجل لمجلس الامن
الدولي لمناقشه وادانت الجرائم
الاسرائيليه في نابلس
اولا شكرا على استضافه لقد التقيت
ظهره هذا اليوم مع رئيسه مجلس الامن سفيره
مالطا ووضعتها بصوره اخر التفاصيل حول
المذبحه والجرائم التي ارتكبت سلطه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد اهلنا
الصابرين والصامدين في مدينه نابلس
الباسله حيث ذهب ضحيه هذا العدوان عشره
شهداء و102 من الجرحى جزء منهم وضعهم في
حرج وفي غايه الصعوبه وفي النقاش والتداول
مع رئيسه مجلس الامن وبعد ان اعطيتها
بيانا مذكره لتشارك اعضاء مجلس الامن بها
وكذلك للامين العام ورئيس الجمعيه العامه
اتفقنا على الاستمرار في
المشاورات وسيمتد ذلك عبر المندوب العربي
الامارات العربيه المتحده الذين نشكرهم
على جهودهم وجميع المجموعه العربيه بقياده
الشيخ علياء رئيسه المجموعه العربيه لهذا
الشهر على التواصل مع اعضاء مجلس الامن
بهدف تربيه الطلب الفلسطيني بشان ان يتحمل
مجلس الامن مسؤولياته وان
يقدم على
اعتقد النفقات
نعم سيد رياض نعم نحن نسمعك بشكل واضح
ولكن بانتظار ان يصلح الزملاء ان يوصلوا
اليك نعم تفضل سيد رياض كنت تحدثت انك
وضعت رئيسه مجلس الامن الدولي في الصوره
ما يحدث في نابلس هلا وضعتنا نحن ايضا
والمشاهدين في سوره
وطرحت نعم اعذبني على المقاطعه ما الذي
يحدث في في نابلس لماذا هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الان برايك وهو ياتي بعد سلسله
جهود للتهدئه زياره بلنكن وحديث عن
مشاورات ربما بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل لتهدئه الاوضاع لماذا هذا
التصعيد الان في نابلس
يعني جميعنا نعرف على ان هذه الحكومه هي
الحكومه الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ الحكومات
الاسرائيليه وتحتوي على وزراء في صفوفها
هم
يعني فاشيين ولقد قدموا الى المحاكم
الاسرائيليه
وصنفوا على انهم ارهابيين وكذلك هكذا
تتعاطى معهم الاداره الامريكيه والحكومه
الامريكيه ولذلك لا نستغرب ان مثل هؤلاء
المتطرفين والفاشين يريدوا تفجير الاوضاع
في المنطقه
لانهم يريدوا من ضمن عده مسائل ان يحرفوا
الانظار عن المشاكل الداخليه الكثيره التي
يمر فيها المجتمع الاسرائيلي على ايه حال
لست انا الشخص الذي يعطي تفسيرا لماذا
يقدم على مثل هذه العمليات عليهم ان
يشرحوا لماذا ان يقوموا بذلك لكن يهمنا
على ان الشعب الفلسطيني يتصدى لهذا
العدوان بكل كبرياء
ولن يسمح لسلطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المستوطنين المجرمين الذين يشنوا غضبهم
وعدوانهم على شعبنا بان يكسروا اراده
الشعب الفلسطيني نحن ندين هذه الاعمال
الاسرائيليه باشد العبارات ونريد لمجلس
الامن ونريد للمجتمع الدولي وللامين العام
شخصيا ان يتحملوا مسؤولياتهم في تطبيق ما
اقر سواء في مجلس الامن ام عبر تقرير
الامين العام في توفير الحمايه للسكان
المدنيين وسنتواصل مع اعضاء مجلس الامن في
الايام القادمه لان يتحمل المجلس
مسؤولياته وان تعقد جلسه لمجلس الامن
طارئه وفق ما اشرت اليه في تصريح وزير
الخارجيه الدكتور رياض المالكي وهذه
تعليمات التي لدي من قبل القياده
الفلسطينيه واشكر الاشقاء العرب على
وقوفهم معنا في هذا المجال نعم سيد رياض
كما ذكرت يعني
في الاقتحامات السابقه كذلك الاسرائيليه
في نابلس جرى بعدها عمليات انتقاميه ان
كان في القدس وفي مناطق اخرى واليوم
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه رفعت مستوى
التاهب الامني الى اين تتجه الامور هل
الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه متجه الى
الانفجار
انا انا لا استطيع ان اتكلم عن غضب الشعب
الفلسطيني
وتصديه لهذه الهجمات والعدوان عليه
وبطبيعه الحال عندما يزداد هذا العنف
من قبل سلطه الاحتلال
والارهاب من قبل المستوطنين ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني يصبح من الطبيعي التوقع احيانا
ردود فعل من البعض على هذه الاعمال التي
هي سلطه الاحتلال مسؤوله عنها نحن من
جانبنا يعني سنبقى ندافع عن قضيتنا في كل
المحافل وفي المقدمه منها مجلس الامن ومع
الامين العام والجمعيه العامه لان هذا
واجبنا وهذا المجال الذي نعمل فيه وننفذ
اراده الشعب الفلسطيني ونتفهم غضبه ونتفهم
انه غاضب على ليس فقط سلطه الاحتلال
والمستوطنين وانما كذلك من نواحي مفهومه
على المجتمع الدولي الذي لا ينفذ ولا يطبق
قراراته في مساله توفير الحمايه للسكان
المدنيين الى ان ينتهي الاحتلال ويحظى
الشعب الفلسطيني بانجاز استقلال دولته
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه اشكركم شكرا جزيلا
على الاجابه عن اسئلتنا الاستاذ رياض
منصور انتم طبعا مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم
المتحده كنت معنا من نيويورك
[موسيقى]
نشرت قناته اننا الامريكيه تقريبا
استقصائيا كشفت فيه عن وجود عشرات السجون
السريه لدى النظام الايراني استخدمها لقمع
المتظاهرين والمحتجين وذكرت القناه ان بعض
هذه السجون يقع في مراكز حكوميه او في
اقضيه المساجد
[تصفيق]
تتعدد الوسائل والغايه واحده سحق اصوات
تندد بواقع لا يحتمل في ايران يبتكر جهاز
الامن طرق تعذيب ممنهجه لفضل احتجاجات
المستمره منذ مقتل رمز الثوره مهسى اميني
سبتمبر الماضي شبكه سي ان ان تتبعت خيوط
شهادات اوصلتها بسلسله غامضه من المعتقلات
السريه في جميع انحاء ايران 30 موقعا
الكثير منها يقع داخل منشات حكوميه كقواعد
للجيش وللحرس الثوري الايراني والقليل
داخل مستودعات او غرف فارغه في مباني او
اقبيه مساجد هنا في شمال شرق ايران في
مشهد تم تحديده ثلاثه مواقع سوداء اليها
جر المتظاهرون مع سبل اعين وتعرضوا لضرب
مبرح وانتهى بهم الامر بكسر في الانف
واحيانا في الا او في الضلوع المعتقلون
ذكروا تفاصيل العنف الجنسي والسعق
بالكهرباء وخلع المسامير والجلد والضرب
المبرح الذي يتعرضوا له كل ذلك تقول
المصادر انه يجري تحت اشراف قوات البسيج
التي تتركز في قاعده النخبه الدينيه مشهد
سطعوني على فمي ووصفوني بالسيئه وصوروني
لاقول ان وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيه اثرت علي
للنزول الى الشارع
ليست فاطمه وحدها من تم سحب اعترافات
باطله منها تحت التعذيب في طهران بل الاف
المتظاهرين خصوصا في سلندر الغربيه ذات
الاغلبيه الكرديه ووفقا للروايات تمثل
المواقع السريه منفذ الاتصال الاول
للمتظاهرين الموقوفين لساعات او لاشهر
لكن مراكز الاعتقال غير الرسميه ليس
الظاهره جديده في ايران الا انها توسعت
كثيرا في الانتفاضه الاخيره
سابقه براي المحللين تعود لخوف النظام من
الاطاحه باركانه ما دفعت به لتكثيف
التكتيكات الوحشيه خارج نطاق الاجراءات
القانونيه وايقاف الاحتجاجات باي ثمن كان
كالرمح النووي العربيه
وفي سياق متصل توالت ردود الافعال
السياسيه والدبلوماسيه الالمانيه بعد حكم
الاعدام الذي طال مواطنها جمشيد شرمهاد في
محاكم النظام الايراني
في اول رده فعل عمليه تقوم بها المانيا
بعد اعلان ايران حكمها بالاعدام على
المواطن الايراني
الالمانيد قامت برلين بطرد الدبلوماسيين
ايرانيين الخارجيه الالمانيه بعد ان
استدعت القائمه بالاعمال الايرانيه وسلمته
احتجاجا على حكم الاعدام قررت اعلان اثنين
من موظفي السفاره الايرانيه كشخصين غير
مرغوب فيهما وطلبت منهما مغادره المانيا
الطرد جاء متزامنا مع ادانه المستشار
الالماني
لحكم الاعدام الايراني ضد مواطن الماني
مزدوج الجنسيه وطالب بالغاء القرار
وزعمت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه ان شارماهد حكم
عليه بالاعدام بتهمه الفساد في الارض
العلاقات بين ايران والغرب توترت خلال
السنوات الماضيه بسبب العنف الذي تمارسه
طهران على مواطنيها والذي انسحب على مزدوج
الجنسيه من خلال اعتقالات واعدامات وصفتها
المعارضه بالكيديه التي يهدف النظام
الايراني لابتزاز الغرب بها
انس بنماسي العربيه
[موسيقى]
حزن مؤجل ممرضون واطباء سوريون نحو
عاطفتهم جانبا للاهتمام بالجرحى الذين
تدفقوا للمشافي عقب الزلزال في مقابله
خاصه للعربيه تحدثت ممرضه في احدى مشافي
حارم في ادلب عن هول ما راته وعن تحولها
اما لبعض الاطفال في المشفى
الحمد لله على السلامه
طفيفه وجروح قابله للتضميض وان حفرت
بعقولهم نالوا الفرصه الثانيه اطفال
اخرجوا من تحت الانقاض ليفترشوا اسره احد
مشافي حارم في ريف ادلب هؤلاء يرون بمن
يعاملهم من ممرضات حضن ام فقدوها او اخفي
عنهم مصيرها في عندي مريضه اسمها جنان
جنان جنيد هي من اطفال اللي طلعت من تحت
الانقاض هاي جنان عندي اياها يعني
ما عندي اولاد فحس فبحسه مثل بنتي خط
الدفاع الاول في الكارثه هذه المره
تشاركته مجموعتان ففي وقت كان عناصر الخوض
البيضاء منتشرين بين الانقاض يتتبعون
اطراف خيطان علهم يجدون صوتا هنا او يدا
هناك تلتمس من ياخذ بها كان الاطباء وطاقم
التمريض على قله عناصره يهرعون من زاويه
الى اخرى لمحاوله من ياتيهم بعضهم لفظ
انفاسه الاخيره على مداخل المشافي واخرون
على ايديهم على واتعبهم يجيبوا لي الطفل
فانا عم باخذه فعم بيقولوا لي عايش عايش
فبدي
بكون انفاسه الاخيره يعني ما بعرف لانه
انا فقدت رفيقتي هون
راحت زلزال كانت ممرضه معنا جابوا لنا
رئيس المشفى فنحن عرفناه استشهد الله
يرحمه فتركناه والتفتنا لغيره
الله يرحمه ففي عالم لسه لسه عايشه لسه
بدها ايانا فنحن رحنا لهنيك الحزن المؤجل
رافق صرخه الخذلان فالاخيره باتت مالوفه
في سوريا وسقلتها حرب ممتده منذ 12 عاما
لتكمل عليها كارثه راح ضحيتها الالاف في
كل زاويه منها هناك من يبكي الفقد ويقول
لو كان هناك امكانيات او مساعدات لربما من
ابكيه ظل موجودا الارض خذلتنا
الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجا انقذ كان
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقفت وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاذ
ساعتين ثلاثه كان ما كان بالاصوات
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه العدل الدوليه
تدعو اذربيجان لفتح طريق حيوي بين ارمينيا
وناغورنو كاراباخ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لاول مره منذ اربع سنوات
محادثات امنيه رسميه جمعت الصين واليابان
تهدف الى تخفيف حده التوتر بين الثاني
والثالث اكبر اقتصادات العالم اما على
طاوله المحادثات كان الخلاف حول التسليح
والمناطيد حيث ابدت الصين انزعاجها الشديد
من زياده اليابان انفاقها الدفاعي
وقدراتها العسكريه في منطقه طوكيو
العلاقات العسكريه بين بكين وروسيا
والاشتباه في استخدامها لمناطيل تجسس
المحادثات تاتي في الوقت الذي تخشى فيه
طوكيو ان تلجا الى القوه للسيطره على
تايوان تجارب كوريا النوويه تاثيرها لم
يعد سياسيا او عسكريا فقط بل باتت تهدد
صحه السكان دراسه صادره عن منظمه حقوقيه
اوضحت ان الاغذيه ومحاصيل الفطر او ما
يعرف في بعض المناطق العربيه بعش الغراب
المزروعه بالقرب من موقع للتجارب النوويه
في كوريا الشماليه تهدد صحه السكان في
جميع انحاء المنطقه والذين يستهلكون الفطر
وتقول الدراسه ان مئات الالاف من الاشخاص
الذين يعيشون بالقرب من منشاه بونجري
للابحاث والتجارب النوويه في اقصى شمال
كوريا الشماليه معرضون لخطر الاشعاعات
المنبعثه من الانفاق والتي تتسرب الى
المياه الجوفيه المستخدمه في الشرب وفي
الري مجموعه عمل العداله الانتقاليه في
كوريا الجنوبيه دعت الى اجراء فحوصات
واختبارات للاجئين الكوريين الشماليين
الذين عاشوا سابقا في تلك المنطقه وفقا
لما ذكرته صحيفه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
دعت محكمه العدل الدوليه اذربيجان الى فتح
طريق حيوي في منطقه ناغورنا كارباخ
المتنازع عليها معتبره ان هناك مخاطر
فعليه من تعرض الناس لما وصفته بانه ضرر
لا يمكن اصلاحه وقالت رئيسه المحكمه
القاضيه في الحكم الصادر عن اعلى محاكم
الامم المتحده في لاهاي انه على اذربيجان
اتخاذ كافه الاجراءات المتاحه لديها لضمان
عدم اعاقه حركه الاشخاص والمركبات
والبضائع على طول ممر لاتشين في كلا
الاتجاهين
[موسيقى]
بعد سلسله من الانقطاعات المتكرره في
التقويم الدراسي بدا جلسات امتحانات
التلاميذ لمرحله الاساس في السودان وبرغم
اصراري لجنه المعلمين بمواصله الاضراب الا
انها ترى ان تعطيل العام الدراسي كارثه
على المسيله التعليميه بالبلاد وترى
اللجنه ان الحكومه لم تستجب لمطالبهم
كامله
العمليه التعليميه تعاني هذا لسان حال
المدارس في السودان
هنا في ولايه الخرطوم بدا الطلاب جلسات
الامتحانات روميسرا لجنه المعلمين بمواصله
الاضراب الا ان بعض المعلمين قرروا مساعده
التلاميذ دون المساس بمطالبهم احنا حاليا
نزلنا المدارس مع ابنائنا لانه المدارس
اصبحوا التلاميذ اصبحوا
راجعين يمشوا راجعين وقفنا معاهم نزلتين
الامتحانات امتحناهم وما زلنا على غامضين
على الجمر على حقنا يعني ما متنازلين
معاناه الاباء والامهات ليست منحصره في
تزعزع العام الدراسي فقط بل امتدت لقيامهم
بدوري المعلم في التدريس والمراجعه لا
يمكن
تقفل المدرسه انت بتطالب بحقوقك بطرق
شرقيه لكن كونه المدرسه تقفل الضرر اكبر
ربما انه العام يتضرر والتعليم ده اهم
حاجه في اي دوله تقدم الرقيه والتطور كله
على التعليم العام
رغم الابتسامه التي تبدو على وجوه هؤلاء
التلاميذ الا انهم المتضرر الاول من اضراب
ينفذه عدد من المعلمين اضراب قد يسبب فشل
او ضياع العام الدراسي
لجنه المعلمين السودانيه تقول ان تعليق
العام الدراسي ليس في مصلحه احد لكنهم
حريصون على حقوقهم ولن يتراجعوا عن
مطالبهم تعطيل العام الدراسي كارثه
المساله دي عشان كده نحن اساسي ماديين
يدينا والله بيضاء
لحكومه الامر الواقعي دي والله ما يدينا
عشان ننقذ العمل الدراسي ده لكن والله
كمان يعني
اه يعني يعني نحن مشينا خطوه تجاهك تعال
خطوات تجاهنا عشان نقدر نقدر عمل دراسه
المخاوف لا تزال قائمه من انهيار التفاهم
بين لجنه المعلمين والسلطات المعنيه في
الدوله حاله اخفاق الاخيره في تلبيه
المطالب التي تم الاتفاق عليها ما يجعل
مستقبل التلاميذ محاطا بمخاطر لا يملكون
ردها سالم الهاشمي العربيه الخرطوم
في خبر عاجل ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا
يرتفعون الى حوالي 50 الف قتيل في كل من
تركيا وسوريا
بابرز العناوين
اطلعتها على خطتها لبدء الوساطه والحوار
معك يبدون بحث التفاصيل
يتعهد بمزيد من الدعم تزيد انتاجها
العسكري لتزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه برلين
تدين حكم الاعدام على مواطننا الماني من
الصين وتطرد دبلوماسيين ايرانيين العربيه
تستقصي الاوضاع الانسانيه شمال غربي سوريا
بعد الزلزال وتنقل شهادات الكوادر الطبيه
شكرا على المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]